devi stare attenta non lo devi far
cadere i detenuti zurita stories oggi il
nuovo episodio della guerra degli
scherzi frank wall street ha organizzato
uno scherzo per unità le parlò porta
così non vivente
ora faccio subito vedere che scherzo
organizzato come negli altri episodi
andremo a farsi degli scherzi presi da
kraft quest'episodio raggiunge i 10 mila
mi piace ci sarà anche un altro episodio
in più alla fine del video
scrivete nei commenti quale scherzo mi è
piaciuto più di tutti ha scritto sto
organizzato ormai sapete che vitale mi
ruba sempre il cibo infatti li ho fatto
altri scherzi con il si muove li
ricordate super divertenti questa volta
di fare un altro scherzo con il sangue
cioè prendeteli nota linea vuoto la
confezione ed entra la confezione metta
uno slam schifoso guardate questo slime
è un mix tra o programma a togliere un
pezzo sotto le bari dovrò fare in modo
che vitale non si accorga che qua dentro
non ci sono le batterie che l'aspetterà
una bellissima sorpresa vitale vitale
vuoi qualche patatina
[Musica]
palladino ciao
che schifo
sulle ma guardi mai arrivati interpreti
o meglio come fosse una salsa questo
estrae a sei mani
[Musica]
e morto questo online prima scandendo
permettere ho visto uno scherzo che è
troppo divertente anche se un povero che
si arrabbierà volta perché questo
scherzo è veramente veramente cattivo lo
faccio subito vedere questo spero che
riuscirà questo scherzo per prima cosa
devo prendere una tavoletta di
cioccolata e scioglierlo ecco la
tavoletta di cioccolata che mettono
nella sedia dai clan per non attaccarsi
alla sedia l'ho messo in questa carta da
forno
ora non mi resta che scioglierlo e poi
chiamare vitale sperando che si sieda
senza corse verso il cioccolato provini
il phon
ok con il fan ci vuole troppo tempo per
lasciarlo in forma senza farmi fini
perché il sorteggio calato al forno
guardate più bello a millesimo charles
leggiamoli un pezzo è buono o che ora lo
sistemo nella serie chiamero pitale
dicendole che c'è un'urgenza che dove
subito vedere qualcosa così non si
accorgerà spero che siamo posizionato la
cioccolata qua per fare in modo che vita
di non si accorga dove si sta sedendo
farlo arrivare velocissimamente farlo
sedere velocissimamente sperando che si
sieda senza guardare la sedia e adesso
come faccio ad aprire così via così qua
ho cambiato i pantaloni perché non
potevo rimanere quelle condizioni è
arrivato il legale la vendetta infatti
le farò uno scherzo che prevede una
bottiglia d'acqua
ho bisogno di questo nastrino per
legarle insieme questo video in realtà
l'ho visto ho sottili tocco su instagram
non ne sono sicuro praticamente qui ho
già fatto nodo a questa bottiglia
d'acqua ea trionfare l'altro nodo anche
a quest'altra bottiglia d'acqua creò
così una specie di peso e incolla aiuto
di un foglio e della farina dai guard
anita guarda questa nuova challenge
riesce a fare questo
la conosce questa nuova challenge no ma
non mi fido siccome però questa messa
alla getur bottiglie lo vuoi provare si
pratica anche di sollevare questioni
bottiglie così devi cercare di tenere il
più possibile fermo foglio con degli
oggetti sopra non l'hai mai provata
no ma siccome ti ho fatto degli scherzi
malefici non mi fido penso che sia un
trucchetto è un tranello mobile allora
se non ti fidi lo farò da solo questo
dato da zero vincerò non hai voglia di
sfidarmi e ad angelica mela provare per
tu allontanati ok e sui certo devo solo
metterci il foglio le cose da tenere in
bilico poi abbiamo montato vendite ma
sono orientate punti viene anche prima
le braccia della silicosi permettiamo
queste auto figlio così il consiste
nell'ottenere due fogli e ribelli bridge
com'è difficile
no non pensano così hart line è
praticamente bisogna aggiungerci delle
cose sopra bisogna aggiungere qualcosa e
centrano potevi far vedere chi stare
molto attenta mi raccomando come
[Musica]
non ci credo io mi batto lì ma perché
effettivamente anch'io
e tu invece che mi hai fatto separa così
se fossi che cada addosso ma resta solo
scherzo più malefico è più divertente fa
quando vai a carico merci vostro scherzo
preferito era state un mi piace se
volete vedere altri certi abbiamo fatto
un sacco di altri scherzi in questa
guerra minute volete vedere gli altri
andate cliccate qui se volete vedere
altri video divertenti perché se volete
vedere videogiochi nella vita reale
cliccate qui per altri video cliccate
qua